shelters are overflowing with evacuees
norah o'donnell is outside the george r
brown convention center in downtown
houston where thousands crammed in and
spent the night nora good morning
good morning maurice that's right
crammed in is the right word as you know
this is houston's main evacuation center
and shelter it is packed with people the
official capacity when they started this
thing on sunday morning they said 5 000.
well officials tell cbs news more than 9
000 people stayed here last night many
of them without beds we went in a short
time ago and let me tell you gail you
and i talked about this it's important
for people to know what's going on many
of these evacuees are grateful that they
are in a dry place that there is some
food but they are also sharing a lot of
frustration with where the things are
going
we were here just 48 hours ago and there
were only 700 people
now there's more than nine thousand
people according to the red cross
[Music]
as you can see
people are sleeping on the ground
they're not enough beds for everybody
when we were here they had 1200 beds
they're trying to get 5 000 cots they
say that means about half of the people
don't have beds that's why they're
sleeping on the floor
michelle where did you sleep last night
and you have three children
where did they sleep on the floor
on cardboard on cardboard
do they not have beds no
and this is disturbing why didn't they
have enough cops
they have not opened up more shelters
those blankets they don't even have
enough blankets there were no blankets
yeah one blanket
for you and the three kids yeah and they
we i wrapped this little
thingy
so i want everybody else
it might have family eight everybody
just have cows
what do people need to know about what's
going on
this this our city is better than this
way better that we can take in the
outside
from the other
we should be treated the same way we
live here
this is our home
you think they were prepared no
they and they still know they still
suffer what do we do
i mean i walked in there i just walked
through did you see
the babies and there's a lady next to us
and she have a little baby that's on the
floor
with his head literally and i have to
let my brother make something to
somebody put in pillowcases so the
baby's head won't be on the floor
so think about what you just heard
and we're just in the beginning of this
i think there are key questions for
lawmakers for state officials about how
you house 9 000 plus people just that's
just at this shelter there are lots of
other shelters how do you take care of
thousands and thousands of people for a
week at a time for how long how do you
feed them this morning we went it was
very orderly and patient but there were
about 300 people waiting for some
breakfast there are no showers no
showers inside and people don't have
clothes they don't have shoes but
there's big tables full of used
um shoes and clothes and so that's where
they're getting and replenishing how uh
how they're living because they're
living inside these shelters
and that comes as this rescue effort
continues today more people emergency
responders have now helped more than 6
000 people trapped by flood waters
president trump is in the air right now
he's on his way to texas he says to
check on the relief operation
his first stop is corpus christi near
the area where hurricane harvey first
made landfall